sure 39 was it Nicolaas here we go also
keep in mind if you want something other
than five minutes standard just let me
know when you punch in your two guesses
if you want 960 or a different time
other than five-minute you could do 5 3
2 1 I don't do any of the increments
because I like to have the time burner
advantage I'd like to be able to time
burn if something goes astray alright so
we could transpose still into lines that
have been played in the championship
let's see d4 d5 let's do it anyhow right
here could still transpose okay the
exchange I really don't like this ah
let's see
well
I need do ecig Knight f6 okay
it's always very uncomfortable for me to
get the Queen Bishop out that's why I'm
kind of like groaning here I don't know
what to do with that light square bishop
well maybe I know what to do now
I'm just fearful like Knight f6 there's
Queen b3 but might I have a pretty
decent reply like in fact maybe I should
play here no no no no no right here
maybe now then I get pushed around
pushed around again maybe pushed around
again my knight so if anything Bishop f5
Queen b3 Queen Queen d7 Knight f3 to e5
that's just so annoying about a 6 b5
Bishop d7 it's a little bit scary
because after a 6 there's Bishop here
and after b5 Bishop already has
potential tactics against my rook a6
Bishop g2 B 5 B 5 seems to be maybe
pretty strong
oh okay I'm not seeing something so easy
to get that [ __ ] about just reinforce
my Center let's do this for right now I
still do have thoughts let me get
castled I still have thoughts of getting
my Bishop to this square mmm maybe this
square where does my knight want to be I
think I want to get here on e4 maybe you
could string my knights together like
this 97 and then fall and want to follow
in one another's footsteps 94 Knight f6
Bishop d7 I'll just kind of directly or
indirectly watching over you for I'm
gonna give that a shot I do have to be
concerned about the c5 square as soon as
I do b5 he becomes a very important
piece to hang on to just so that I do
watch over the c5 point so how this what
I'm gonna run with and now well if white
goes with this I could think about
Knight d7 and they get it to the c4 I
think this is exactly where it belongs
and rook here rook c8 Queen b3 maybe
just double on the C file this Bishop
isn't so hot either you know I don't
have a great Queen side Bishop neither
does white so they're having to figure
out some stuff and it's pretty hmm close
to a symmetrical position if you just
negate these bishops here well no no no
no no not really I was imagining things
here okay the Knights are connected but
they're on different squares they need
to be shifted boom boom but I guess okay
we have a symmetrical central punch
structure that's getting pretty specific
but okay seventh-ranked weaknesses what
is that white is looking to do this
efore advanced apparently I think right
here is a good move to run with placing
this pawn and a pin if this move is
played the move e5 is not a threat and I
think I should just play this move right
now let's go with it
so I mean there's a downside to it in
that now this night could pivot about
here this is this becomes an isolated
pond it could become a target of course
and I might actually be losing a pond by
force here
let's see hopefully as compensation
you're on the numbers on that one too
well but I do get activity and well even
if I do lose a pond again look how this
king is a bit you know vulnerable here
not no ponds on the second rank so even
if in some lines I kind up losing that
deep on getting a rope to this second
rank and forcing the King back and maybe
mate threats and you know if the king is
not on that uh I gotta go like this if
he isn't on h2 to watch over these guys
maybe I could be getting them and this
is what I was fearful of this advance
hitting the night and now this pond is
hit for a third time and I think this is
best putting pressure on e if Knight
takes okay well we're not having now if
we had a bunch of exchanges I think I
keep taking until the Queen is here and
then I take on this Square and then
Bishop takes Queen takes but oh and then
I'd have to come back here if there was
a rookie one move but anyhow we're not
having that Knight f5 is pretty real
possibility they're actually how about i
reinforce this pawn before I lose them
night here though I want to be in a spot
to back up my bishop I think it's a very
annoying night but I'm down a time to
okay let's see
rook e8 Knight f5 bishop we're gonna
have to go with this III really think I
do need to hang on to my deep on I can't
okay I better go quick too
so now for the for the one moment I am
watching over f5 I am coordinated right
here on the e4 square this is a
purposeful move I think I stand better
my rooks maybe have a better influence
on the position let me go here for
starters I might want to come back over
here
I think the rook did its job in watching
over this pawn maybe I want to annoy
this Knight right here let's do that
that could be annoying and well now
there's not Knight here because the
Queen is then overloaded having to watch
over both nights I'm gonna go with this
Knight first not sure that there's a big
difference but do that first if Knight
here threatening the bishop and me I do
have Bishop f6 as a response so this is
a guy that I definitely have to work
around now I need to stop me get that
Queen out of there
kick that night away the Knights in a
pin but now now what can I do I need to
move quick flight square and look to get
in some break over here maybe there's
some capture at some point on this
square need to get maybe some more
pieces over here I could double on the C
file I really have to sort things out
quickly maybe that was the most direct
thing I did consider Brooke c3 but
that's actually a bad move just snip the
knight and then the rook knight is
pinned I really don't want to take it
actually that's difficult to get out of
that pin to up Knight there what about
rook here right now
I'm gonna do this move now if Bishop
here I'm gonna take the night to keep
this close I don't want to open up I
have control over the only open file and
now I'm going to take here doing it only
knowing that what I might be trapped if
I take this pawn Queen c2 and if I take
on g3 mine no I didn't mean to do that
why do you do that I just said I don't
want to do that maybe it's okay okay get
over here
huh I didn't mean to do that I just
saying don't do that okay what do we got
Bishop here everything is okay oh that's
exactly what I did not want to see let's
come over here I'm on g3 stops Queen
takes pawn oh they missed that Queens
are gonna be coming off the board
right here there's got to be made to of
15 come on where's the I should just
giving it oh I missed that should just
give it a check on g3 what am i doing
they got a mate thread whoa whoa whoa
whoa I don't want weak in my dark
squares like that this is no good
why can't this be easier how am i doing
rook see to let it work no no no right
here I just want to get the Queens off
please just get the Queens off no no no
where's my time I don't have any time I
should take in the rook I definitely
should have taken that rook where is it
I don't have any time ah
why did that pun oh man oh good game why
do I play butch III oh man ah let meet
the rewind button on that good game
let's flip let's flip aru ski uh in that
ending uh why was I wasting so much time
I almost almost fell for a mate I think
there was that Bishop right there I did
not want to move my pawn on g6 Oh that
weakened my darks were so bad okay let's
see where this is at here okay I was
team white I don't like this variation
either but okay I like the position I
got and this is a no case this is a good
setup this is fine we have g3 e6 let's
get to the exciting stuff here so this
was a little bit weird
just the coordination of the Knights
there um what else okay so it's still
solid
and what yeah this was this was an
interesting position right here as soon
as well even right here as soon as you
go with f3 this is a very committal move
f3 and then with E for f3 and then e for
right around the corner I just wanted to
strike right away before this move is
played so capture capture I play Knight
c4 could you take this pawn I get this
pawn back and I think I'll I think I
stand better cuz yeah actually it would
be this guy that white would be giving
up so going for that capture is probably
not a good choice good decision by white
I night's kicked away rip defense I come
back over we have the pair of nights off
ah made threat I have to watch over that
the Knights in the pen I love this
position I was happy with that where did
I chew up all my time I think right here
was one spot right here right here I was
saying don't capture the pine and I
captured the pond
I think Queen c2 and I end up having to
like grab the bishop or go back here if
I take here Queen c2 and I all I did
take that Queen c2 and then how do I
save my rook right if I take this pond
there's Bishop takes Knight and then
King takes rook I'm in trouble so I
think Queen - Queen c2 was a shot right
there but now it's not because I have c2
watched over I could have also maybe
even taken on this square a lot of
missed opportunities this one stung look
at look at how close I am after king
here I just give a rook check and this
is leading to me this is just leading to
me ah man check a ruski followed by
checkmate I was on this is what I was
thinking right here
well after I capture this pawn I was
just thinking no matter what white does
I'm just gonna leave these guys here
because I was assuming the Queen was
just gonna block she had blocked a
couple and I was already on my way to
just doing something else grabbing that
pawn ah man that was a main mr. Tate I'm
eatin a few and this was a good move
this was a good move putting pressure on
my pawn if I play here there's just
Bishop takes and I'm a dead man
Queen g5 I got the Queen's off but I
don't have any time ah
and I shouldn't take in the rook missed
opportunities ah good game good game
alright let's close out